- Pay the fuck attention to
who's giving you the advice.
Who's giving the advice?
And more importantly,
if you live your life
where you're comfortable
taking somebody else's point of view
on how you should fucking live your life,
you deserve to lose.
("On My Way" by Reo Cragun)
♪ I been working this damn
job for a minute now ♪
♪ Back and forth to the Costco,
I gotta cut it out yeah ♪
♪ Taylor wanna seal the deal,
yeah she wanna play house now ♪
♪ Shit I'm only 21 that's
a lot to deal with now ♪
♪ Man I gotta leave the city ♪
♪ My chick acting iffy ♪
♪ Swear the whole thing temp me ♪
♪ Get it now, I gotta get it now ♪
♪ Gotta put it in position ♪
♪ Gotta go make a difference ♪
♪ My palms been itching ♪
♪ Oh no, oh no ♪
♪ Don't you look back no ♪
♪ Don't you slow down ♪
♪ Don't you look down,
we're at new heights now ♪
♪ All on my feet and my heart ♪
♪ I'm on my way, on my way now ♪
♪ I'm on my way yeah, I'm on my way ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ Said I'm on my way ♪
♪ Stay out of my way yeah ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ I'm on my way ♪
♪ Where he at now ♪
♪ I'm the talk of the town
and got something now ♪
♪ I'm ducking obstacles
now, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I just gave them two cents ♪
♪ Then they drew me up
a blueprint, oh yeah ♪
♪ Halle, hallelujah ♪
♪ I been dreaming lucid,
yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ But I had to leave the city ♪
♪ Had to do the heavy lifting ♪
♪ It didn't happen in an instant ♪
♪ No it didn't baby, no it didn't ♪
♪ Had to put it in position ♪
♪ Had to go a long distance ♪
♪ My palms been itching ♪
♪ Oh no, oh no ♪
♪ Don't you look back no ♪
♪ Don't you slow down ♪
♪ Don't you look down ♪
♪ We're at new heights now ♪
♪ All on my feet and my heart ♪
♪ I'm on my way, on my way now ♪
♪ I'm on my way yeah ♪
♪ I'm on my way ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ Said I'm on my way ♪
♪ Stay out of my way yeah ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ I'm on my way ♪
♪ I'm on my way yeah ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ Said I'm on my way ♪
♪ Stay out of my way yeah ♪
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ I'm on my way ♪
- It's bullshit because when
you listen to outside voices,
you're always going to regret it.
My vision's pretty simple.
Would you rather appease
the inconvenience right now,
in the short term,
or do you wanna sit
around as a 78-year-old
and fucking regret how
you lived your life?
That to me is the question.
Are you willing to take
the short term lack of pain
by conforming to the fucking system,
or do you actually wanna do
something with your life,
because this internet thing,
the fact that there are
three fucking cameras
in this room right now,
the fact that a million people almost
on Instagram followed you,
this is available.
There are so much fucking
departments in the system.
Everybody can get there.
♪ Hard work done paid off ♪
♪ I'm on my way ♪
- Some will get billions,
some will get millions,
some will get hundreds of thousands.
But wouldn't you rather
make $87,000 a year
talking about Star Wars
because you love it more than breathing,
than make 109 being an
accountant for that shit firm?